at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
hey what's going on here we are again
yep and I say every time I'm off the
camera yeah get the hell yeah
what because you're hogging it
you're not gonna push each other
get out of the other video
and they'll be like who's this [__]
yeah
you're liking a review you're like in a
movie review yeah or some [__] like that
all right so with my luck I'd end up in
like some [__] stupid ass
[__] yeah you know what I mean
yeah
um
Zach says Tom I was half asleep and you
sent me all his messages last night and
I thought I was having a dream no the
messenger typing sound effect oh what
did you what'd you do did you send him
dick pics no he wishes
[Laughter]
no I was telling I was telling them
about uh we haven't said anything about
it but I told him it was oh the new
project
you're telling her about that was that
what you're doing after you got home
because you he went out to bike night
last night oh was that bike night and he
was asking oh okay okay you know I had
my device with it yeah well yeah I know
because I saw like because you sent me
some messages too but yeah he went to
bike night last night yeah by the time
he got home I was like half asleep yeah
well we're gonna do this next time it's
gonna be
we're gonna do the cab show and he's
horrified he's like okay you guys are
gonna [__] yourself out and I said we
were yeah yeah
what's wrong with that
have you been listening to our stories
and who we hang out with yeah yeah
so I guess so I guess the cat's out of
the bag then yeah but uh yeah we're
gonna um we're still gonna keep the show
but we're gonna we're gonna open up
another we gotta we got another Studio
we're gonna set up in here and we're
gonna do some [__] cam work yeah yeah
and it's gonna be funny it's gonna have
it's gonna have horror themes and
cosplay and it's gonna have its own
Twitter and it's on Instagram it's gonna
have a real [__] hot
photo shoots of Jan and little clips and
stuff and uh you guys will like it yeah
it's gonna take us a while to get us all
together yeah it's gonna take a while
but there's [__] we got to do yeah and
we gotta do a bunch of test stuff and uh
we're gonna uh film some we're gonna
video some uh
scenes and [__]
those will be for sale this [__] is
going to be free it's gonna be for sale
you know
right well yeah but it's gonna
definitely be branded you guys will
recognize exactly everything that's
going on man I'm gonna dress up as Bane
yeah I'm good well I was kind of picture
I was kind of picturing it like a
Sidetrack show like yeah but go going
many steps farther yeah
yeah for the right price [__] some
[__] will go down
I might just be dressed up in a wolf
costume like a werewolf you never they
can't tell I might be on Trend who knows
we will definitely be drinking well yeah
that's that's gonna be the fun of it
yeah and I got a huge supply of Viagra
he's already prepared yeah
yeah it's gonna be fun though yeah I'm
looking forward to it and and um we'll
see I mean we just
we just need other income streams I mean
uh Jenny's now working a full-time job
she's not all that happy with it [__]
she wants to work for herself then we're
really used to working for ourselves for
ourselves from our own home office here
we got enough equipment enough Talent
where we're
we could do whatever we wanted
it's just we needed
quick income uh that was reliable so
Jenny just had to go back to work yeah
but it's it's temporary
we're gonna come up with some cool [__]
yeah we'll try to find something yeah
like I said I'm just I'm I'm you know at
this stage of my life I'm like I haven't
really never been cut out for like
normal yeah life or normal jobs and
stuff we're both basically entertainers
so we'll figure something out yeah I
think it'll be fun thank you Jack
Torrance what do you say just said
here's Johnny Yes there you are yeah
um Danny Rowling said Tom shouldn't one
up Jenny and get some dermal piercings
on his areolas just saying yeah he's
never gonna do that no after I've done
that myself and realized how tough that
material is I'm never gonna let anybody
[__] shove a [__] needle through
there the first time I went away you did
mine though I had to keep a stiff upper
lip don't do that first and I was like
God damn I didn't really want to go
through that second one I didn't I
didn't want you to either I was like man
I was really I was like man I really
need like to take a few hour break and
like yeah and then I was like dreading
it like we sat there and watched a movie
and the whole time I was like oh I don't
want it I was thinking like yeah that
[__] wasn't too Pleasant I thought it
would just slip in and out because I put
needles through myself all the time
doing injections injections and [__] I
um I thought it would just be like like
going through butter no it was more like
going through a real hard rubber it was
cracking and popping and [__] [__]
some good year titties that's what I am
yeah good year titties yeah the nipple
is a [__] very elastic material I
wasn't expecting that just you know in
case you didn't know yeah
Tammy says oh my God I saw Renfield last
night really recommend it okay oh good
like I said it looks super funny like I
really really wanted to see it and
matter of fact speaking of Nicholas Cage
because Nicholas Cage is in it um and I
think American Military 100 mentioned
earlier uh there is a movie about this
case that we're gonna be talking about
tonight Robert Hansen and it's called
The Frozen Ground And if you have Amazon
Prime you can watch it for free and
indeed I was watching it for free I
didn't get to watch the whole thing I
watched probably like a little over half
of it I started watching it on my phone
like on my lunch hour and then when I
got home like I put it on but I didn't
get um it seemed okay like American
Military 100 said he thought it sucked
but I thought it was pretty good but
it's they dramatized some of this it's
fairly accurate it seemed like
um up to a point but they did kind of
like dramatize some of the stuff and
like made a couple of people like bigger
characters than they were in real life
you know just like they would do in a
movie you know what I mean
um and then Danny Rowling is also
talking about uh the Beast of Jersey
which we will get around to doing him
like eventually like I said I keep
putting him in the poll and he never
wins you know what I mean because I want
to do him one of the show on them too uh
Dana Rowling also said city morgue
worker Kenneth Douglas was convicted of
more than 100 necrophilia rapes would
have gotten along with tonight's guest
yeah probably this [__]
I don't know I feel like I say that like
every time we do a serial killer show
I'm like ah this is like the worst
[__] ever this dude
this is one of the few people that
actually did [__] like this and this is
some [__] cold-blooded [__] this dude
did yeah I remember him but I don't like
all the details
he's basically reenacting a [__] most
dangerous game story just capturing
people and releasing them and hunting
them down girls yeah hookers I mean yeah
he's just this dude is just like a piece
of [__] I mean like I said I'll see you
know serial killers by their nature a
piece of [__] but this dude yeah I don't
I don't know the whole details but we'll
find out [__] man like I said he just
seems like a complete [__] psychopath
and this is another case too that it
just kind of makes me mad and I know it
was like the 60s and 70s and [__] but
it's like this is another dude that so
many times got caught for [__] and just
like got off with like a slap on the
wrist and should not have you know what
I mean like nowadays
he'd get caught one time and they'd be
like yeah we're putting this
[__] away because we know what
we know what that's leading to but back
then they were like oh it's fine it's
fine it's just a minor problem yeah and
then they would just let him go and then
look what happened so you know what I
mean that's it I don't know it just made
me angry like and I know that it's easy
to say like because you know hindsight's
20 20 and bloody blah like yeah we know
what a monster he was now but and back
then they didn't know that but I just
feel like a few times they absolutely
should have kept him incarcerated for
much longer than they did and they like
just let him go because of
just lame ass [__] because they thought
that he wasn't a threat and I'm like
well I beg to differ uh he absolutely
was I would probably do the way he
looked yeah he was um yeah he was real
unassuming and another thing too was
that um he was kind of like an
upstanding member of the community which
you know yeah you should you should
never feel like a Raider yeah you should
never yeah you should never just like
use that as oh he's probably not a
serial kill I'm like you know
you know I did other things you know I
did some good for the community it was
you know yeah I had some problems I had
some sexual problems but
you know I worked at the church and I
did a lot of good stuff
kept straight dogs out of the
neighborhoods make sure everybody's
Lawns were cut you know
make sure I think I think dogs will poop
it in the yard I think it was a net
benefit I think I was a net benefit to
the community
I mean it was only a couple women
yeah I mean there's millions of people
in the world yeah yeah no ones are bored
every day they would have died
eventually anyway
you know he probably did think some [__]
like that oh yeah yeah of course that's
probably how they would have died
eventually anyway this [__] too
seemed like I mean he wasn't an incel
because like he did you know have wives
and kids and stuff like that but he was
one of those [__] that you know
I'm getting back at all the women of the
world because women didn't like me like
girls didn't like me in school like one
of those kind of [__] they're
bad let me get some more ice yeah so you
know there's there's that too so I mean
the dude's just he's ticking off all the
boxes isn't he
um Danny Rowling said there's an 81 film
worth reviewing called butcher Baker
nightmare maker oh yeah that's right uh
it's on shutter or it was I don't
remember if I watched it though I was
gonna watch it and I was but then I
don't think I got around to it
um
yeah Camp guy said I think this guy had
a living room or Den full of mounted
animal heads and trophies that's kind of
creepy to me yeah he was actually
um a uh he was well known as like a
hunter like where he lived like he even
had some [__] like in the record books
and stuff like that like biggest doll
sheep like killed or whatever it was you
know what I mean he was a crossbow
Hunter too and like I said he was known
around there for being like a really
good Hunter nobody knew he was hunting
people though until like later on so you
know that's nice
um yeah murder Hornet said um this is
how Tara was visibly upset yeah and some
of these girls uh that got killed these
girls and women well some of them were
just girls because some were teenagers
but yeah they were also visibly upset
and um they're asking about Evil Dead
rise I still I want to see that too
and let's see xanet is here
and well uh
I'm just looking at all the stuff okay
oh and Zach says I have a topic
recommendation
um hold on I can't see that arnfen
nessit one of the only uh Norwegian
serial killers a nurse who poisoned a
bunch of elderly people see I'm always
kind of fascinated by that kind of stuff
too I know we did like an angels of
Mercy show where we covered I think
three or four different cases of
[__] that did that because that
does seem like a lot of female serial
killers will go that route
where they just like poison people yeah
in hospitals wasn't there a nurse that
was killing newborns yeah well that's
been more than one there was a British
one that was doing that and um
yeah and I still want to go back to like
some of the old like some of the old
days ones like Amelia Dyer and stuff
like that like that baby farmer lady and
all that kind of [__] throwing them into
Thames and [__] yeah well every of all
the bodies got thrown in the Thames back
then yeah I mean it was just like
is I don't know if it was this bad but I
do kind of feel like in the Victorian
era like the Thames was just like one
big like mat of just decomposing bodies
because it was like people were just
dying and like their own and it was just
like [__] and everything yeah it was raw
sewage pretty much
it's not that bad anymore but you know
what I mean back then they were just
like they had no clue there's like yeah
let's just live in filth yeah why not
why are we sick all the time well there
wasn't any uh Community planning or
anything either
that's true I don't think they really
planned centralized
irrigation and Wastewater and all that
came later but
I mean I don't even think in some of
those some of those uh
European
cities they didn't have a way to get rid
of the horse [__] you guys had horseshit
piled up yeah
well that's the thing I um
I probably recommended recommended it
before but there's like a really great
book called uh the ghost map and it's
about
um how they found the uh cure for or how
they figured out what caused cholera
and it was just like this one
neighborhood and like this one doctor
because back then everybody thought that
you know just bad smells like made you
sick you know what I mean they didn't
realize that it's like oh drinking [__]
water was probably not good for you so
it's just kind of like sewage was like
leaking into like these water pumps in
these particular neighborhoods and this
one doctor you know Against All Odds
because everyone else thought he was
crazy
um he like very meticulously went and
was like okay well this family got sick
and died like and they he like mapped it
out from each water pump like in the
neighborhood and like where you know
where the [__] was coming from and stuff
like that you would think the concept of
cross-contamination would be a given
that you would think that you would said
that would be yeah if you were to piss
in a tub of water and then went back and
drank it you'd go back and drink it you
would know that would not be good
because even animals are grossed out by
their own waste yeah for I'm for exactly
that reason I don't know what the
thinking is what went into the water the
water cleaned it
maybe or it's it's well water's clean so
anything I put in there is washing it
water cleaned so you can now drink it I
don't [__] understand you would think
that [__] and piss or [__] you see it
going into the same [__] River you're
drinking out of and you drink Downstream
of it because nowhere no matter where
you go in this in in the river you're
always Downstream of it because there's
somebody throwing some [__] and and piss
in the in the river there's always
somebody
where you're standing
I said I'd go I ain't gonna drink that
water you know what I mean but I don't
think they drank out of the Temps but
well I you might have had to if you were
poor I think they would have known that
that was not good
for some reason they thought the water
in the wells was good maybe they didn't
know what the water table was
yeah maybe not I kind of feel like a lot
of people back then didn't know much of
anything
drinking poop water they're like why why
is everybody dying given you know giving
enough distance you know clay and sand
and mud will filter stuff well sure but
then if it gets totally saturated it
can't filter because it's just all in
there you know what I mean it's just
going through a [__] sponge a piss
yeah
[Laughter]
man this has been a really Pleasant show
Goodyear boobs and piss sponges yeah
that's that's the [__] that you won't
get anywhere else except on this but
it's [__] you all right so let's talk
about this [__] this
[__]
so uh this all took place in Alaska in
and around Anchorage
now the thing about it okay we'll get
into I don't necessarily usually I would
do stuff from like uh you know uh
chronological timeline but I don't think
I'm gonna do that this time I think I'm
gonna go like from not necessarily the
discovery of the first body but the
discovery of the first body where they
realized that maybe something was amiss
and then we'll kind of like go back and
like pick it up because this guy
had been killing people they found out
later since I think 1971 but they didn't
actually catch him until 1983.
so in that time
they believe that he killed at least 17
women possibly as many as 21 and
possibly more than that um I've also
seen the number 37 thrown around
um and on top of that he also uh that
they know of raped an additional 30
women that he did not kill so and you
know so he's dead now uh he died in 2014
in prison thankfully so how many did he
kill again 17. they think at least that
many at least at least that many all
right and then but probably more and
then probably raped about 30 that he
didn't that he didn't kill at least like
I said there's probably more because it
was a long period of time where he was
dude it was a serious misogynist man
yes yeah I I think that's that's a fair
statement to make yeah I think that's a
fair statement to make yeah
um he was the thing about it
um
I think that he was one of those guys
you know he was a very Madonna horror
type of guy
like I kind of because he had a wife and
then like he had a second wife like he
had two wives not at the same time
obviously but um so he did and he did
have a family like he had kids and stuff
so I kind of feel like he made a
distinction between you know he was
compartment good girls and bad good
girls and bad girls yeah and so if you
were um you know a sex worker then you
were just trash and you deserved
whatever happened to you kind of thing
which you know is sadly a very it was a
very common and I think the reason you
know the um the fact that's that even
some in law enforcement had that uh had
that view as well maybe went some way
toward why he kept getting away with
[__] or you know why it took so long to
catch him because a lot of the women
that went missing like no one really
looked for them yeah you know what I'm
saying so they didn't really find [__]
out until later yeah we've been we've
been over this before another uh serial
killers that take prostitutes
I think part of it is that the cops kind
of give up real quick well she's a
prostitute and see the thing is is you
can't trace who she's been with right
because they're moving around in secret
it's many dudes a day and you'll never
be able to figure it out through police
work and her body would be
cross-contaminated anyway probably with
DNA they didn't have DNA back then
anyway yeah it should have been
contaminated with fibers and different
hairs and they just you never figure out
who it was
and I think a lot of times too what
happened in this case was that you know
a lot of them were going missing but
they were just like well you know
they're sex workers it moved away it's
right it's Alaska it was a very
transient population at the time which
we'll get into a little bit and so oh
you know it happens all the time they
just move on to another place they don't
like it here anymore or yes something
like that so they didn't really even if
they were reported missing which a lot
of them were
um you know by family members or
employers or whatever
um they didn't really look for them all
that hard they only really found them
later on like after they first started
to realize that maybe there was
something well another thing is that law
enforcement can't really look for them
they don't have time they can't there's
too many yeah that's true they they find
them they go oh here she is yeah yeah
dead okay they can't find them they
don't have time they got other [__] they
got to worry about
active crimes involved active crime yeah
and I mean that's what's sad and that's
the thing and I think that and this guy
in particular Robert Hansen and I'm
thinking of also like some other serial
killers really like the Long Island
serial killer and stuff like that is
they know that law enforcement are not
you know that usually sex workers are
lower priority like when they go missing
or when they get murdered or whatever so
a lot of times they will you know
specifically Target they'll try to look
for a child but then that's when that
that might only be the day that the
child went missing yeah you know and
then but the the the the
the trail goes cold quickly yeah you
know they'll put out apbs and [__]
try to figure out try to figure out what
what vehicle the kid got taken in you
know but finding somebody especially
back in those days is a lot harder than
you think
and the police have to do their normal
job their normal daily job they're doing
you know they're holding down [__]
crime and doing conducting traffic and
all that kind of [__]
they have a baseline that they have to
have to do you know and then all the
detectives are going to be busy with
crimes that they know happened like they
have bodies and that they have to
[__] finally kill these people a
missing person that's not really a crime
it's just a mystery especially if it's
an adult yeah and that's what like I
even watched because I watched there's
an FBI Files about this and that there's
like a British one that was good and one
of the cops on there even said that it's
like you know it's not illegal for an
adult to go missing you know on purpose
so it's like you can't even if they get
reported missing that's not real I mean
unless there's you know some reason to
think that something really bad happens
yeah I'm like a break-in and then
there's blood right yeah obviously
they're gonna do the car's gone yeah but
if a girl you know if a woman who's you
know in her 20s who you know was a
dancer in a club or something like that
and she just doesn't show up one day you
know they're gonna be like oh well she
just moved on to other pastures or
whatever they don't really got a
boyfriend yeah they don't really worry
that much about it which in some cases
is that is what happens so that's why
they think that but not in these days
mostly what happens that's Yeah well
yeah that's what I mean so it's just
kind of like
you know were they always you know like
if a teenager disappears they always
kind of oh well they're a runaway which
you know if they turn up dead later on
that looks really bad on them but most
of the time they do turn up all right
you know what I mean they did just run
away or something else happen so you
know there's a reason why they think
that but
like I said hindsight's 2020 like uh you
know these women obviously did not go
missing of their own volition uh some
bad [__] happened to them
so
so even though so like I said even
though his crimes probably started in 19
in the early 70s but he didn't really
get caught until about the 80s when they
first figured out what the hell was
going on
so this is happening right around
um Anchorage Alaska area now in the 70s
and 80s Alaska was kind of like well
because they were building that oil
pipeline or whatever so there that was
kind of like where you went because
remember I said it was like a really
transient population they said it's kind
of like it was kind of like the wild
west out there because people were
coming out
to work on the oil rigs there was a lot
of money to be made out there
um so you got like an influx of people
and they said it was real common for
people who you know maybe were trying to
escape their life in the lower 48 maybe
they had some stuff that they were
running away from uh you know some
crimes or something like that so a lot
of them be like well I'm just gonna
start over you know in Alaska so the you
know the population was very transient
you just had all these dudes like
working on oil rigs and then they had
like in Anchorage in particular they had
like this one strip like a red light
district like you would in any kind of
like old west type of thing
um you know where all of these girls and
dancers were there was like very very
common
uh you know prostitution was very very
rampant and there was also like a lot of
crime as well
so
1982 it was September of 1982 to be
specific
so there's these two guys and they're
out hunting they're actually off-duty
police officers
and um you know it's Alaska it's
Wilderness largely uh so I don't know
like if you're not from the United
States Alaska is more than twice as big
as Texas and most of it is wilderness
um so you know a lot of people go there
like outdoors type stuff they go hard
time there's twice as big as Texas it's
more than twice as big it's massive
that's like four times the size of
Germany it's massive yeah
um but like I said the population is
relatively low so most of it is just
like a Barren Wasteland yeah that's
where Bigfoot would be yeah
Bigfoot lives in Alaska yeah but yeah so
there's a lot of hunting up there like
you know there's black bear there's
moose there's all that kind of stuff
so these two guys uh whose names were
John Daly and Audie Holloway um as I
said they were both police officers from
Anchorage and they were out hunting uh
one day on their day off along a river
called the Knick River
now the two guys
um they've been hunting all day and
they're like okay well it's getting dark
and they decided they were going to set
up camp for the night
now as they're going along the river
they see what appears to be a boot
sticking out of the ground
now they didn't think anything about it
at first they just thought you know
maybe somebody lost a shoe or maybe or
sometimes it was like you know dead
hikers or dead hunters that happened a
lot too because you know but you know a
hunter would get lost or somebody was
hiking or something like that and they
succumb to the elements because it's
cold as [__] up there
so um because they were both cops though
they're like maybe we should probably
check that out so they go over there and
they move the shoe and uh they found
underneath the shoe probably not
surprisingly
um like a partially decayed foot and leg
so um since they were both cops they
knew okay we need to like not they just
backed off the scene we can't don't
touch anything we're just like call for
backup and everything like that so they
get all the cops out there they're
taking pictures of everything and all
that other kind of stuff
so um they also started to looking they
were looking for evidence
um you know what had happened to this
person because they said that that it
had clothes on
um and it was clearly not a hiker like
it didn't have you know the body didn't
have like clothes on that connoted a
hiker so they start like sifting through
the sand
and they find a single shell casing from
a 223 caliber bullet um one of the cops
recognized it and said oh that's you
know that's a high-powered rifle you
know uh ammunition right like a M16
Mini-14 yeah or an AR-15 technically if
you said high powered rifles you know
he's talking about it's intermediate
it's an intermediate rifle cartridge
it's in between Rifle and Pistol
um
high power is a lot bigger like 30 odd
six 308 seven millimeter Magnum you know
but uh it is it's about that long
uh the 22 caliber bullet but it's just
usually the Spire point
and uh
the casing that holds all the powder is
a lot bigger than 22.
um caliber it's almost as big as a long
nine millimeter cartridge and it's next
down to 22.
it's a not weak but it's not strong
either it's in the middle
so they take the body back to Anchorage
and do you know the autopsy
so they find that this
um individual was a woman uh they
weren't sure how old she was
they thought she had been dead because
of the rate of Decay for about six
months
cause of death was three gunshot wounds
from the 223 caliber bullets
uh there were also they found Ace
bandages in with the remains so they
surmised that she had been blindfolded
interestingly too and this was something
that happened with uh several of his
victims is that even though the body
when the bodies were found they were
clothed
the clothing did not have any bullet
holes in them suggesting that the women
were naked when he killed them and then
he redressed them before burying them
because he's a [__] freak hmm you
know so there wouldn't be a bullet hole
in the clothing but there would be in
the body right
how many shell cases did they find on
this at this scene at this particular
scene they just found the one but they
found three bullet holes in her okay
he's using something like a Mini-14
we'll see that is that is what it is
yeah okay spoiler alert well I just
thought I would tell you so you okay
it's yeah it is a mini voice because
it's semi-automatic and it's five five
six and in that area in that day it
would have only been uh Colt sp1 which
was like a semi-auto M16 or the uh the
Ruger a Ruger
mini 14 which is what you saw in The
A-Team remember that movie the 18th
that's what they were I mean I haven't
seen the 18th in such a long time uh
I've owned them M16 is much better a lot
more accurate but they were Mini-14 was
cheaper they had a wooden stock it
looked like a 30 car being
and it was a little more like a
traditional rifle
it's just kind of mediocre
they weren't very good at full auto but
that's what you know not many military
sales
with more of a
civilian rifle
some prison guards used it I think the
Italian Navy used a stainless steel
version of it
that's about it not very remarkable
they had full auto versions they weren't
very good though
not very controllable
Camp guy is talking about some other uh
serial killers that specialized in
prostitutes Samuel little oh yeah we did
a show about that [__] Gary
Ridgway yeah
Anthony that's so it's so well isn't it
Anthony cell yeah like I said a lot of
serial killers do kind of and whoever
the um you know there's like the Santa
Rosa hitchhiker murder some of them were
prostitutes um Texas Killing Fields a
lot of them were prostitutes stuff like
that because they think those were
probably truckers those serial killers
so it took about two weeks
but they finally identified this young
woman as 24 year old Sherry Morrow
now she had been a topless dancer at a
club called The Wild Cherry bar in
Anchorage like on the red light district
there
now she had actually been missing for
several months uh she was last seen
alive in November of 1980
uh one 1981. I'm sorry I couldn't see it
there for a second
and the last thing that she told her
friends was that
um she had an appointment like a guy had
offered her 300 to pose for some
photographs like he said he was a
photographer and then went back down
yeah this is back in like 1981 yeah so
um yeah so that was quite a bit of money
so um like 600 bucks right that was the
last anybody saw of her and she had been
reported missing but you know they just
they found her six months later
now this particular body being found
this was not the first
situation like this that had Arisen it's
just that prior to this the police were
still kind of
sort of holding out hope that these
crimes were unrelated you know what I
mean
but you know finding this one they're
like okay we're pretty sure that this is
a serial killer now
but in the two years prior to this
um there had actually been not just
bodies found but there had been like a
kind of a spike in missing persons
reports and many of them were of the
same
um type they were usually younger women
like from 16 to you know 28 years old uh
were usually kind of like smaller like
120 pounds like kind of you know smaller
petite women
um and they were usually sex workers or
topless dancers or something like that
not always
um but a lot of them were and a lot of
them had been reported like I said there
had been a spike in it
so um you know but before that like I
said the cops were just kind of like
well a lot of these women just kind of
like take off and indeed like some of
the women that were reported missing
they did find them like alive and well
later on
um so they were like oh we'll see you
know not all of them but you know some
of them obviously they didn't find
so uh they also wanted to I guess they
also wanted to forestall they were like
well if there is a serial killer out
there we don't want to make too big a
stink about this like in case like we
don't want him to like take off you know
what I mean like because he'll know
we're on to him or whatever
so basically though and I saw um
yeah like a documentary where they were
talking about this is that so now
they've had this body that was found and
then they had like all these other women
all these other women missing and they'd
actually had kind of a um
they kind of a press conference where
they specifically kind of came out and
said we don't think these cases are
related I don't know if they actually
thought they were related at that time
or if they were just saying that like I
said to keep
everybody calm or whatever but
um you know they didn't think it was one
person
at first
so
essentially what they what they did then
was that they started looking back after
they found Sherry Mora's body
they started looking back at some of
these other like a couple of other
bodies that they had found previously
so they went back to this one case from
1980 which was still unsolved uh
actually there were two cases from 1980
but the first one that they looked into
there was actually these workers like
they were digging like a um you know
they're construction workers or whatever
and they were digging near a place
called aklitna Road
and they found
um uh remains in a like a buried and
shallow grave like a woman's body
now the uh the body was only partly
there um because you know Wildlife it's
Alaska so it had been partially eaten
um and this there there wasn't really
anything I don't think they found any
shell casings or anything like that now
sadly this woman has never been
identified this woman that they found
they still
um call her eclipna Annie and that's the
only name that she's uh Gone by they
still have not identified her to this
day
now later on in 1980 they also found
another body like in a gravel pit like
not too far away I think it was like
only a mile or two away
now this victim was actually identified
later on uh this was a woman named
Joanne Messina she was also a topless
dancer
um and they didn't really find much
evidence with her body either and her
body was also very very decomposed
I wonder if
application isn't that these tapest
dancers were pulling tricks on the side
well yeah they were they were yeah some
of them were well because either that or
it's hard to say because the way that
Robert Hansen would usually get them was
if they were open to sex work he would
just say hey can you know can I have a
[__] for whatever and they would just
get in the car
or I think if they weren't down then he
would say I'm a photographer and I'll
can all give you money to take pictures
of you pretty much right he would uh
make that offer to strippers yeah okay
yeah and that was enough to get your ass
killed yeah all right
well the
I mean the weird thing about it too is
that sometimes they found out later on
he didn't kill everybody he picked up
okay
you know what I mean because remember
like I said they think he killed at
least 17 women probably more but they
think that he also just raped at least
30 women that he didn't kill so he must
have thought
if you were stripping and taking photos
and [__] you were bad so he could rape
you
he said some [__] yeah one thing that he
said like really kind of struck me like
when they went should you save it well I
no well yeah well because we're getting
to that party okay we're getting another
part
so like I said so they're investigating
these three bodies that they found like
I said they found two in 1980
um one of them unidentified and they
didn't really those cases never really
went anywhere because there wasn't
really any evidence and the bodies were
really decomposed and then they found
Sherry morrow in 1982. again they found
a shell casing but that was about it I
mean obviously they knew she'd been
murdered and they knew that like
something really bad had happened but
they didn't really have that much to go
on
so at this point like I said they're
starting to think maybe this is the same
guy
but they didn't really they couldn't
really go forward with it however
um I was gonna say luckily but not
really but I guess luckily in the sense
of like the helping to finally catch the
[__] not luckily for the girl
though
um what ends up happening in June of
1983.
um there's this truck driver and he's
driving through town like down I believe
it was Sixth Avenue
and he sees a half-naked young woman
with handcuffs on
waving his truck down and [__] like that
okay she was like that can't go through
in front like screaming for help yeah
yeah right
um
and so he basically he stops thankfully
and she gets in and um she's like
there's a man is after me just [__]
drive right like he's gonna kill me
now she wanted to be taken to uh the Big
Timber Motel which I think I guess that
that was where she was living
so she gets to the motel she asked the
desk clerk to call her boyfriend she
doesn't call the police
and
um then she like Waits outside for the
boyfriend okay I get it now the truck
driver he's like well
I'm gonna I'm gonna call the police yeah
so he um please because she's out there
trying to tricks well yeah which on
honestly like considering what happened
to this poor girl
um I think I probably would but the
thing about it is that you know she's a
sex worker uh she probably hasn't had
that many good experiences with cops you
can see how she probably was like not
just trying to get the [__] out like I
don't yeah I'm just gonna get the [__]
out of here and forget this ever
happened like I get it you know what I
mean but yeah
so the truck driver
um just he dropped her off and then he
went to the Anchorage Police Department
which is the right thing and reported it
yeah the cops know that motherfucker's
out there hunting yeah like yeah because
they found out later that he was that he
was chasing her oh yeah with his gun and
he was like I'm gonna kill you I'm gonna
kill you [__] I'm like why and she was
like running around supposed to be
handcuffed or did she get away early she
got away early that's what I figured he
was gonna take the Cuffs off of her yeah
yeah we'll get into that because yeah
because we'll get into that like what
happened
so um so the officers show up at the Big
Timber Motel where the girl was
um so he finds her there she's still got
the handcuffs on she couldn't get the
get them off
so he took him off for
and you know he's like you know what the
[__] happened to you so she told him
she says
this guy walks up to me and she gave a
very good description of him she said um
he was about 40-ish
um he had kind of red hair
um he was kind of slightly built had big
glasses had a stutter
um and kind of a pockmarked expression
or uh complexion rather like you know
acne Aggie scars yeah
and she said that um
he said that he would give me 200 to
give him a [__] oh man so I mean in
1983 she should have known something's
wrong
yeah that's a lot of money in 83. yeah
she's probably more used to hearing like
40 bucks you'd think yeah I'm not really
sure what the going rate was in in 1983
I don't know what the going rate is now
to be honest but um depends on the
caliber I guess the caliber of the woman
I guess yeah
so um she's like okay
but she gets in the car
and she starts to do it and he put the
handcuffs on her and like put a revolver
to her Temple like in like one motion
damn he's fast yeah
um well they found out later that he'd
done it a bunch of times and he called
it muscle memory yeah because he'd done
it automatically yeah he just did it
really fast
so he basically says well if you just do
what I want then I won't kill you
which you know great Famous Last Words
yeah
so then he drove her to his house
which was kind of like a nice area
so she saw his house yeah okay
and um
so he takes her inside
takes her to his what he called his den
which is kind of like his trophy room
and it's like I said he was an avid
Outdoorsman and Hunter and he had a
whole room like it was like a man cave
but it had just like deer heads and bear
heads and yeah just all that kind of
[__] like all over the place so like a
little a little creepy you know I mean
he takes her down there chains her to a
pole like a or you know like a pole like
in the middle of the room so I guess
he's not with his wife when he's doing
this
um his wife this at this instance was
away okay like him and he had two kids
too they were way too they yeah the wife
and the kids I think were in Europe all
right they were on vacation all right so
he's feeling comfortable yeah
so um so yeah he horribly raped her
several times sodomized her
um bit her nipples damn
get him off or just bit him I don't
think he bit them off I mean Jesus
Christ I can imagine tough as those
things are but you know damn yeah now
that we've had some experience with that
yeah but um
and also she said um shoved a hammer up
into her vagina
so he does this to her like over several
hours
and then
um he decides he's going to take a nap
for some reason because he it warms he's
tired yeah I guess and I'm just like
oxytocin and she's like chained to the
[__] gonna like holy [__] I can't I
can't imagine I can't imagine what was
going through that poor girl's head oh
man she's [__] freaking I would be
freaking I mean seriously how long did
you sleep I don't know okay
so he gets back up and he says oh I
really like you I'm going to fly you out
to my cabin in the woods
and you know you can stay with me for a
while like I go great
like I've done that with with some other
girls you know that I that I liked you
can like stay with me I won't hurt you
or anything like that I'm like
[__] you already hurt me what
the [__] are you talking about and
um yeah she said later on that she um
because I read some of her transcript
and she was like he just kept saying
don't worry about it I'm like
[__] I'm worried okay just Jesus
Christ and the fact and she even said
later on she said the fact that he told
me that he had taken seven other girls
up there she immediately knew he killed
those girls yeah yeah like you know what
I mean like he she knew the [__]
score right because you know she would
hurt about it right alive right
so yeah so she's like flipping out
and at this point she said I think it
was at this point that she decided you
know first opportunity I gotta get the
[__] out of here because he's gonna
[__] kill me
so
um that's good thinking if you guys
don't know anything about survival
escape and evasion for military they say
your best chances of Escape are when
you're first getting captured because
you're healthy and you're [__] aware
you're you're well fed that's the time
to escape soon as you get captured
it's your best times
okay go ahead and another thing is you
want to escape with the [__] in the
middle of a snowstorm or a
[__] rain downpour anything that'll
slow down vehicles I mean they always
tell you too don't let the [__]
take you to a second location don't let
them be never let a person take you
anywhere alive make them kill you on the
spot if they take you somewhere it's
gonna be worse than death anyway
yeah the problem is a lot of women don't
have a choice dude comes up knocks them
out pow yeah
yeah you don't really have a choice
there's no choice because if they can
pick you up most women don't weigh
anything
but if you get a chance if a dude says
get in the car I'll shoot you go [__]
shoot me yeah yeah just one yeah he'll
shoot you in the back run zigzag yeah
yeah I mean anything like I said it'd be
better to be shot than like whatever the
[__] he's gonna do because he's got
something in store you don't want to go
through it no
so yeah look what happened to this poor
girl and I mean she did get away though
so he's like all right I'm gonna fly you
to my cabin in up in the mountains
and she's like oh yay so she's like
percent she's like I kind of like
pretended that I wanted to go and like I
wanted to go along you know what I mean
so
um he drives her to Merrill Airfield
which is where his plane was he had like
a little uh Piper Super Cub or whatever
and then he now I've seen two different
sources of this uh either he was packing
up the plane and she was still in the
car or he just or he shoved her in the
plane and then started packing the plane
up I don't really know like either way I
thought she was still in the car you
know what I mean but something said that
she was that he put her in the plane but
at any rate
um he turned his back for a second
um you know to load some things into the
plane she said she specifically saw him
loading a rifle into the plane and was
like oh [__] no I need to get the [__]
out of here this girl had the presence
of mind she took off her tennis shoes
and left them in the car so she could
prove that she'd been in there like when
she reported it later on I'm like can
you imagine having that much [__]
like thinking that much ahead I'm like
just naked with tennis shoes off she was
I don't know she was naked naked but she
was like not not all that dressed you
know what I mean like she had some
clothes on but I don't think she had
many clothes on but she still had shoes
on
now it was pretty cold out you think
it'd be hard to run without the shoes
well I mean if you're running for your
life I'm sure yeah kind of like yeah she
was running Barefoot like down the
[__] road
when they when the trucker picked her up
yeah
so but yeah she had well you said the
trucker said she was naked
well see I don't know I've seen two
things I've seen different things like
the sources some of them said she's like
mostly naked some of the most women say
she was like half naked like when I saw
the reenactment it looked like she was
just wearing like a torn up shirt and
underwear all right
um
right he was driving around a car he
couldn't drive around totally naked yeah
because people would never noticed yeah
so um so yeah but she had the presence
of mind to leave her shoes in the car so
like I said when she told the police
later like she could prove that she'd
been in there and then she just busted
open the the car door and started
[__] running
and um the guy obviously you know Hanson
he sees her and starts like running
after her and he's like I'm gonna shoot
you you [__] blah blah blah and he's
like and she was just like [__] that and
she just like kept on running
the weird thing is like I heard the
weird thing is like I heard some of his
like testimony because they like you
know when they interviewed him one they
did his confession
um you know they recorded it obviously
and I heard like a lot of clips of it
and he didn't stutter much on there okay
so I don't you know but apparently he
had like a really bad he had a really
bad stutter
but I didn't notice him stuttering
during that particular thing but maybe
that was just because it was short clips
or whatever
so um he's gonna say it was in trial no
this was the confession rehearsal you
say is right he was reading it yeah
maybe well no he wasn't reading he was
just being interviewed okay yeah
but like I said maybe it was just
because there was like Snippets maybe
they cut out the parts where he was
stammering I'm not really sure
so uh so yeah so she tells all this to
the cops
and they actually drove her to Merrell
Airfield
and she immediately said that's the
plane like she immediately recognized it
uh it was like a blue and white like I
said it's Piper super cup
and they also
um so they you know it had the tail
number on it so they checked with the
flight Tower and they figured out like
who it belonged to
and they had the address Robert C Hansen
from old Harbor Road
so then they took the the girl whose
name was uh Cindy Paulson by the way she
was 17 years old
um so they took her to the hospital
so then this is the 17 year old girl
uh-huh damn okay like I said she was
turning tricks yeah damn okay
now I I'm not sure if this is the case
but
um because she's kind of a big character
in The you know fictionalized movie that
they made about this was called The
Frozen Ground and they kind of made her
like a really big character and they
kind of made her so it's like oh she'd
been you know on the street since she
was 11 or something like that but I
don't know if that's the case you know
what I mean
um I think she had been doing it for a
while though
so
here's the thing so all this stuff
happened they find out Hansen's address
from the plane because she said that's
the plan that he took me in
so they go to his house
and he
um so Hanson was home and they were like
uh hey what's up what's all this about
this girl named Cindy and she said that
you did all this stuff and he got really
really mad
and he said I've never even met her
before my life she's probably just
trying to shake me down for money that's
what he said
um and then he says to the cops you
can't rape a prostitute can you
yes he didn't think so
so I'm like so that kind of gives you
an idea of like what his mindset is that
it's like they're not people to him I
guess yeah
I'm like yeah you absolutely can or is
he trying to say is he trying to say
well I paid her how is that rape is that
what is that what it is maybe I don't
know if he did pay her though right well
he's probably gonna lie to the cops I
paid her you know so that means I can do
whatever I can kill her I want to drop
the money
I mean that's [__] up
but the fact that he said that I was
just like I think I'd have just like
punched him in the face if he'd said
that
so um yeah he said well yeah my wife and
kids are in Europe they're on vacation
but I couldn't have done what you said
because me and my two buddies were
hanging out
all night like I was over at their house
we were just having some beers and
having guy time or whatever but he's
saying the wrong things and well here's
the thing and both of those guys backed
up his story oh really okay
so the cops were like oh okay well sorry
to bother you sir
got away with it he had an alibi Well
for now for now for now
so yeah so he gets away with it for a
while
however uh not too long after that
um on September 2nd 1983. how did they
explain the handcuffs
see
they I think that they were saying
because here's the thing
not only did Cindy Paulsen describe the
[__] airplane yeah she
described his car in great detail she
described what he looked like in great
detail she described the inside of his
[__] house including the den and like
the thing now the chains weren't there
because he had moved them
right but everything else was exactly as
she said now the fact that they just the
cops went and he was like oh I never
even met that girl even though she like
described every single [__] thing see
that's the thing that they were thinking
well you know just because she's been in
the house that doesn't prove anything
you know what I mean it's like maybe
gone wrong right maybe it was consensual
or maybe yeah maybe she just went and
maybe she got mad because he didn't pay
her enough or something like that so
maybe that's what they were thinking and
the thing about it too was that Cindy
because she was not I mean she gave them
like you know a super detailed
description of everything and you'd
think that would be enough but they
asked her to take a lie detector test
and she wouldn't because
I think she was upset that they didn't
believe her you know what I mean and she
was just like [__] you guys because like
I said she wasn't real trusting of the
cops anyway because she'd been like a
sex worker for a while and I so I think
that that kind of pissed her off that
they didn't believe her and like were
trying to get her to take a lie detector
so she refused and I think too that that
was another thing that made the cops was
like maybe she's making it up even
though like I said there's no way she
could be making it up because she had
all those [__] details yeah she
probably also thought they were gonna
ask ask her things about her other work
and she's afraid she would get in
trouble right
yeah yeah that might have been too I
mean she was just 17. she's still like a
kid you know what I mean but
that's you know so I think that was
another thing too that the cops were
just kind of like ah you know [__] like
it happens sometimes and it's like maybe
she's just maybe she just got mad at it
I mean blah blah and the thing she went
back to the streets
I don't know actually
um but the thing about it too is that
another thing you have and I haven't
really got too much into this yet but um
Hansen was a you know I mentioned this
earlier an upstanding member of the
community I mean he owned a very
successful local bakery
um you know the cops went in there and
got donuts yeah uh you know all the time
probably did the maple logs right a long
time that's all yeah I was just reading
about something about the maple law the
other day and I was like that does sound
good doesn't it I haven't had a maple
log in all yeah like since I was a kid
but yeah so
um yeah yeah appleberry cloth mmm man
we're gonna get some donuts I haven't
had Donuts I'm getting a drink you're
gonna stop talking about food man
we're getting fat just thinking about it
but um but yeah so he so he was very
like I said he had a wife and a couple
kids
um you know he went to church and all
that other kind of crap so it was just
it was like a BTK situation where nobody
thought
nobody thought that you know and he was
very kind of like mild-mannered and
bloody blah even though if you scratch
the surface of that this that's one
thing that kind of makes me mad and yes
I know it was the 70s and 80s and yes I
know they didn't have like all the you
know all the records weren't
computerized and [__] like that like
they are now so it was like a lot harder
especially if you're you know a rest
record was from another state or
whatever but when they first you know if
somebody had just taken like 10 minutes
to like look into this dude's history
they would have found all kind of like
sorted [__] that would have maybe given
them pause and maybe like made them
investigate him more but they just never
did that
they were just kind of like well you
know it's it's the word of a 17 year old
sex worker who won't take a lie detector
test against an upstanding member of the
community who everybody knows you know
what I mean and so she didn't really
have much of a chance
so after that not too long after that
September 2nd 1983.
uh they found another body
um also along the kinnick river uh not
too far from where uh Sherry Morrow had
been found
this woman was later identified as Paula
Golding she was also 17 years old and
also a topless dancer and a sex worker
from Anchorage
she had actually been missing she had
been reported missing five months prior
to her body being found
and when they did the autopsy they found
that like all the other victims she had
also been shot with a 223 caliber bullet
so yeah now they're like well duh um
this is clearly a serial killer
now
there's you know it's Alaska they have
had their fair share of serial killers
uh there was a guy named Thomas uh bunde
I think um he murdered some women in
Fairbanks so you know not Anchorage but
you know
um so basically that dude like killed
himself by the way like before they
arrested him
so what they decided to do
in this hi your little head pop it up
oh my God
thank you mango never trust an
upstanding member of the community I
trust business more yeah see that's what
and I'm not saying that all upstanding
members of the community are serial
killers
um am I but no
um but I'm just saying that just because
someone is an upstanding member of the
community it doesn't mean you can like
write them off as a suspect you know
what I mean because I feel like that
happens too much especially if the
accuser is somebody that's like oh they
they're a heroin addict or they're a
prostitute or whatever it's like you
know yeah but that doesn't mean that
person didn't do some [__] up [__]
though they're asking me to put a wig on
all right I'm gonna put a wig on but I
better get a super chat for this [__]
okay
he's he's pimping himself out yeah
don't let Pookie into the closet because
she she's coming right behind you
stick there look at her eyes are huge
yeah
look at her look at her
every time you open a closet she tries
to go like way around like that because
she thinks she can't see her she's like
what I'm going past around and then she
goes and then she runs in there
you know what I mean [__] redneck the
[__] up oh you're putting on your Joe
Dirt your Joe Dirt rednecking the [__]
out oh my God
putting on my [__] you can't even
Kenny Rogers wig
do you know where to hold them and know
when to hold it gotta know when to hold
no windfold
know when to walk away
no wind to run
yeah you don't look so much like Kenny
Rogers you kind of look more like who's
that other that other [__]
um [__] I don't remember all the country
singers names I don't know
man
all right I'm back in 1981. oh okay so
so it is relevant to the show yeah it's
relevant to the show all right
so what they decided to do in this
instance now that they were pretty sure
that this was a serial killer and I kind
of feel like a lot of them did think
that it was maybe Hanson but they didn't
have enough
um you know evidence
so they decided to call in the FBI to
assist on the uh you know on the case
now interestingly this case involved the
very famous
um John Douglas who if you don't know uh
wrote the book that the show mind Hunter
was based on one of the early FBI
profilers now interestingly profiling
still kind of in its infancy at this
point um you know like I said if you've
seen mine hunter it kind of goes into
the you know the birth of the whole
criminal profiling deal
but I kind of feel like still in 1983 it
was still seen as like Voodoo a little
bit maybe thank you again mango mango
damn it's the missing BG brother yeah
man
I thought you were gonna sing some
beaches I can't think of lyrics man
you can't think of the lyrics no I'm
good I'm good okay I'm good you know I
was looking at this I was looking at
them you know if this wig was
real dark brown it had an eye patch
that'd be snake pliskin
you could dye it maybe yeah
it might be a little bit Danny Rowling
said is this killer still alive no he
died in prison in 2014.
um of natural causes when he was 75
years old I'm gonna make porn in this
wig
I don't know if I can get into the I
don't know if I can get into the corner
with you
okay Lynnwood slash that I saw the
frozen ground with Nicholas Cage yeah I
was just watching it like before the
show I didn't finish I didn't finish
watching it
but um it was on Amazon Prime so I
started watching it and yeah John Cusack
plays Robert Hansen which is crazy
because John Cusack always seemed like
he was such a nice person and I'm like
for him to play a serial killer he's
pretty scary in that [__]
um but yeah so John Douglas a very
famous profiler
so
they asked him uh him and his team they
sent him all the information that they
had about who this killer was they
didn't you know say it was Hanson or
anything like that but they're just like
here's all the details about all the
cases that we have so far you know wow
us make you know who who is it that's
doing this
John Douglas
came back in his team too because I
think it was like a team effort ow my
ring got caught in my hair look at that
ouch ouch ouch that was like
oh I figure yeah Jesus Christ
I swear to God I can't move without
catching something catching on [__] it's
because you're embellished and so pretty
isn't that what it is that's what it is
yeah and yeah until I go and I gotta get
caught and everything
so um basically this is what the dude
said
he said
um that this
killer will be somebody who was uh
bullied when he was younger somebody
who's probably small of stature
someone who is an upstanding member of
the community
someone who is an avid Outdoorsman and
Hunter
someone who has a pronounced speech
impediment either a stutter or a lisp
that's what he said
isn't that crazy it's like [__] magic
man they must listen to the testimony of
the girl
no I don't think they did though I don't
think they did though because because
they were like super impressed like when
he came back with that they're like how
the [__] did he know that you know what
I mean
but it was like super super suspicious
um
yeah so also yeah so when he got when
the um when the profile came back like
all the cops were like holy [__] that
sounds just like [__] Robert Hanson
it's like he was talking about him and
he's never even met the dude
um and also he said and he said this
about other uh serial killers that
Target prostitutes they said that is
usually
um somebody that is trying to get back
at women as a whole because they felt
like women didn't like them so that's
kind of the situation here as well
um and he's like getting revenge or
whatever
so yeah
um as I mentioned every single one of
these points matches Robert Hanson to a
t like I said you might as well just be
[__] talking about him even though he
wasn't
um he also John Douglas also said that
this he is a serial killer that will
keep um souvenirs from his victims so
that's one thing that you want to look
out for if you you know search his house
or whatever
so
at this point the cops are still kind of
like sure not sure
the thing about it was that even though
a lot of the cops
didn't really believe Cindy Paulson's
story or didn't think it was as big a
deal as she was making it there was
actually at least one cop I think his
name was um Greg Baker and he actually
went Rogue a little bit and kind of
looked into Hanson when he wasn't really
supposed to be doing that because he
actually really did believe her and he
said I think this guy is a serial killer
and somebody needs to do something about
it was this um he was one of the cops
that investigated the case like I said I
think his name was Greg Baker so he was
an investigator yeah yeah and um or
maybe just like an officer but he it was
he was mad that like the other cops
weren't really taking it all that
seriously like weren't taking her story
all that seriously and he's like I'm
pretty sure this dude is a monster and
we need to get him off the [__]
street so he kind of did an end run
around the other cops and went right to
the state troopers because the state
troopers were like the ones finding the
bodies and stuff and he said I think I
know who this dude might be and so he
kind of started working with them like
on the down low yeah for you guys that
don't live in the United States let me
explain some
the American law enforcement within a
state and of course there's 50 states
they're kind of divided up you're going
to have the state is divided up into
counties
and inside a county there might be
little municipalities you're going to
have County police and you can have
certain city police or Town Police too
and each one of them are kind of
separate organizations they're they're
they they do kind of work together
inside a county there's a it's like an
umbrella thing uh but they're all kind
of like in some ways kind of like
private contractors all right well above
all that at the state level running from
the state capitol are the state police
and those guys answered basically to the
governor
it's kind of like the state's version of
the FBI
and when it comes to the Quality law
enforcement in any state in the United
States those state troopers the state
police that's the the the the standards
of training and recruiting is uh
High those are your best ones they're
good real good
you know but you know you might go to
some Podunk town
you know population
500 people there might only be two cops
there
and they're kind of like
I don't want to call them glorified
security guards but kind of is what they
are they have
some of them are good though you know
real good firearm skills especially if
they're country boys they just grew up
with guns I mean you know but they just
don't really have the the funding and
they might have two vehicles you know
they just don't have the power to track
down
uh something like a serial killer and uh
because they're kind of
this is of gross generalization but
because of small town cops are caught up
locally minded and kind of small
I want to say small-minded but
they're kind of close-minded so
they don't really like to think of
anything out of the ordinary anything
out of the ordinary they kind of reject
it
and a serial killer is out of the
ordinary
and some girl telling this wild story
of an upstanding citizen tried to hunt
her like an animal they go oh yeah
[__] they would just blow that off
but a State Trooper might go huh might
be something to that because that fits
patterns and especially back in these
days yeah to today that wouldn't fly
today they crop that dude's ass
and rightfully so yeah they should have
done it back then but but back then they
law enforcement wasn't as organized and
they weren't as educated as they are
today and I'll say educated they had
good education it's just that
there was no internet
they couldn't share information across
agencies and across departments
so they're kind of isolated they were
low information that's a good way to put
it low and I remember those days having
low information affected your opinions
because you just didn't know yeah you
weren't no you didn't know what was
normal
you just knew what was normal from your
point of view
which maybe was kind of like provincial
yeah not a very provincial idea of what
your point of view was
but it's not like that now really in the
days of the internet everywhere in the
United States is pretty much like
everywhere else in the United States
you'd be out in the middle of nowhere
they got the same internet as everybody
else their mentality is the same as
their warehouse pretty much now it
depends on the generation
the older people they didn't change much
but you go to a 20 year old or 25 year
old out in Podunk he's just like a 20
year old in New York in a certain way
same kind of
because they're growing up more online
than anything else
Mr 88 said back in those days a local
cop would not know about the murders
outside of his jurisdiction and could
not see the bigger picture yeah yeah and
I think that definitely played into
because the thing about it as we will
get into when I get into Robert Hansen's
background
um he had an extensive criminal record
um but they didn't really think to check
it you know what I mean that was a good
idea that he went to the state police
yeah this one cop I think it was one cop
or I've seen some source to say it was
two cops but one cop in particular yeah
um really thought like he really took
Cindy Paulson's story seriously and he's
like we need to do something about this
but nobody was doing anything it was
just a small smaller town cop could go
to State Police and get it get in front
of the right person
some kind of a high caliber investigator
to go look some shit's going down in the
county where I work and
the small time cops these small minded
kind of small town cops are not seeing
the big picture all right this is what
this girl said and I think this
[__] is a serial killer and up
there they'd go okay we're gonna look
into that [__] yeah because I mean the
state troopers are the were the ones
that had found been finding the bodies
right and you know they were probably
starting to suspect some [__] too yeah
you know what I mean in a state the
state police the state troopers have a
bigger budget
and uh
more time you know what I mean so they
could they could we're going to get on
that it's their there's their it's their
they have the authority they they're
they're supposed to step in you know and
go okay guys step out of the way let us
look at this [__] and that's what they
do
they've got seniority yeah
so um another thing that John Douglas
the profiler said
because the cop said well the thing
about it is that you know he has a
really good Alibi for the time that this
girl said that he was doing all this
stuff to her
John Douglas says to them I think that
he got his friend or his friends to lie
for him so look into that because I'm
pretty sure that this is the dude right
so basically what they decided to do was
kind of lean on the friends
a little bit to see if um they would
kind of uh go back on the story and
actually what ended up happening was
that I think one of the dude I think the
neighbor that he said he'd been with his
name John Henning I think was his name
and his wife actually came out like when
the cops were searching Hansen's house
she came out and said hey what's going
on over here and they said oh well we
think that you know Hanson has something
to do with bloody blah and she was like
oh my husband gave him an alibi and but
that it was [__] like they didn't
hang out that day so you know what I
mean so there went his Alibi and that
was like pretty much the only thing but
yeah the he did get like people to lie
for him and the weird thing about it was
that I'm pretty sure from what I read of
Cindy Paulson's testimony that she told
the cops that he had said that to her
I've Got Friends who'll lie for me or
who will give me an alibi I'm pretty
sure that she said that he said that he
told her that so I'm assuming she told
the cops that so I don't know why you
know like you would think that she if
she told the cops hey he said that he
was going to get some people to lie for
him you'd think that they would check
that out more I don't know why they ever
just take like somebody's word for [__]
you know what I mean like especially if
it's your buddy or your spouse or
something like that I'm like there's
gotta that can't be the only reason that
you like oh well I guess that's the end
of the case then I guess he's not a
serial killer like why would you just
take like some random motherfucker's
word for it I don't know I don't know
that's what I'm I don't know
just the fact they decided they'd forget
now interestingly uh so they wanted to
get a search warrant for Hansen's house
because like I said Douglas the profiler
had said you know this is what will
probably be in his house they will
probably be like all these weapons
they'll probably be
um all of these uh you know trophies or
like souvenirs from the victims stuff
like that so he basically gave them this
big long list of like stuff to look for
and like where it might be and
everything like that now they didn't
have a huge amount of like hard evidence
but they went um to get a search warrant
and as far as I know this case is kind
of like I believe historic because this
is the first time that an FBI profile
had been used to obtain a search warrant
in the United States I think this was
the first time that that had happened
and this was like in 1983.
so they did get the search warrant
though
now
um another thing that they found out
when they were looking into Hansen's
background
was that because they thought well maybe
if they um you know if there was like a
lesser charge they could like bring him
up on so you know in case like the other
stuff didn't go through
they found out that he had actually
purchased his plane
with the proceeds from
basically an insurance fraud what he did
was he stole some like hunting trophies
and [__] like that like from his own
house and he hid them somewhere like he
buried him in the backyard or some [__]
like that and then he reported the [__]
stolen to the insurance company and they
fell for it so he ended up getting like
thirteen thousand dollars like in back
then money so he bought a plane with
that and I've also heard that he bought
his Bakery with that too because like I
said he owned a bakery
but I don't know if that's true or if he
owned the bakery before that but he for
sure like bought the plane with the
money from the insurance fraud so they
did find out about the insurance fraud
and they're like okay well we maybe we
can use that like as a backup you know
what I mean because that's totally
illegal too
so
um so yeah
so they go with this affidavit they get
the search warrant
so in October of 1983
um they basically uh they went to the
bakery and picked up Robert Hansen and
they were going to take him down to the
station for questioning now he did not
resist he did not ask them why he was
being taken there or anything like that
he was just very very calm so they they
took him down to the station and started
uh questioning him
now while they were questioning him for
several hours and this was interesting
too and this was also done at the behest
of John Douglas the profiler they said
when you bring him into the room he had
staged the interrogation room
um just particularly for his uh
psychology so it's like they put out
like all like pictures of the victims
and stuff they had everything like
arranged in a particular way that like
John Douglas recommended
so yeah so they took him there and they
started questioning him so then
meanwhile like some other officers went
and like started searching uh Hansen's
house now I believe the wife was home
um I don't know how she felt about any
of this as far as anyone knows his wife
didn't know jack [__] about [__] she
thought
um she was like super super religious
too I think they were lutherans
I think that
at least um from one from a couple of
documentaries that I saw she just
thought that he was [__] around like
she knew that he was going to
prostitutes but I don't think that she
suspected that he was like raping and
killing them you know what I mean I
think that was
the extent of what she thought he was
doing he thought he was cheating yeah
she just thought he was like you know
cheating on her but not killing people
because
I just kind of feel like most people
wouldn't think that about their spouse
you know what I mean so
and because you think like oh I know
this person really well and blah blah
but you know what I mean do you ever
really know another person probably not
yes you have lived together [__] 24 7
for almost 10 [__] 13 years yeah I don't
I don't think he's not gonna touch it
okay now we have the same hair
yeah I don't think you could be a serial
killer because I don't have time you
don't have time
you're never a way longer yeah I don't
have time to be a serial killer I don't
have time I got time for that and I mean
I could be a serial killer I guess nah
you're always in here working yeah
that's true yeah I'm always working I
don't have time to be a serial killer
who's got time I'm just gonna be heavy
metal right now okay I'm dancing all
right yeah
so what be the dancer or Conan
dancing we're gonna Rush
look at he he came and sit still I'm
trying to talk about like some serious
[__] and he's just like wandering around
it's like wandering around
like like a two-year-old
uh all right I'm listening I'm in the
show I'm here I can hear you okay
just because I step away doesn't mean
you stop okay
so they got this they got the search
warrants so the search warrant was not
just for his house they also um could
search his plane and his car and I think
his workplace like his Bakery so they're
gonna search all the [__]
now um so what ends up happening
they start searching the house now they
don't find anything in the plane or the
bakery anything like that it's totally
clean
so at this point they're starting to get
a little bit discouraged so they start
like searching the house and they find
like you know a bunch of weapons and
stuff but they're like you know nothing
it's none of the weapons that had
anything to do with the murders or
anything like that they're like he's a
hunter so it's not really that big a
deal that there's like all of these uh
things in the house
um so they're kind of like well [__] we
didn't find anything
but then
they found I believe it was underneath
like tucked into like hidden in the
headboard of him in his wife's bed
they found this box and inside it was
um like an aviation map like an aerial
map of the area like the connect River
and there's a bunch of little x's on it
oh [__] and they noticed that some of
those X's corresponded to some bodies
that they had already found except there
was a [__] ton more on there and they
were like oh no that's a [__] a treasure
map right dumbass so then they searched
even more like and then they went up
into the attic and they pulled up all
the insulation
and they found
the 223 they found that up in the attic
and they also found a whole bunch of
jewelry that have belonged to the
victims just like John Douglas said they
would he said that he would that he
would be keeping jewelry or driver's
licenses or something like that and
indeed they did find uh some very
distinctive jewelry that had belonged to
some of the dead and missing women found
it in the Attic so they're like
obviously
this is the guy
so
um yeah who is this guy let's
rewind and like talk about his
upbringing and all that kind of stuff
so Robert Hansen born in 1939 he was
actually born in Iowa
his dad was a Danish immigrant uh his I
think his mom was American though now
his dad was also a baker that's where um
you know that's where Robert got the got
the [__] from
now Robert
and I'm not saying this to excuse him
but he had like a pretty rough childhood
like I said he was kind of
uh real skinny
um he had a real bad stutter he had um
you know when he got a little bit older
he had super super bad acne
um you know which obviously they were
just kind of like pus and sores like all
over his face also him and his dad um
didn't really get along like his dad was
very very strict and very domineering
and made Robert work in the bakery
um you know for real long hours like
from a pretty young age also
um he was naturally left-handed and this
was pretty common back in those days
um for whatever reason they thought
left-handed people were defective or
satanic or something there was like some
so they would often um if you started
writing with your left hand which was
natural to you they would whack your
left hand until you made you right with
your right one yeah
um and that's what happened to him and
um he said that he found this so
stressful that it made like the stutter
even worse because of the stress of
having to you know of getting beaten for
writing with his natural hand
so there was that Sarah's in there
called dad's a [__] dancing was not a
[__] [__] he sucker punched him
anybody could knock out anybody if the
if the blow is right you know I don't no
that wasn't buzzy
he was just it's just hard being a
Satanist in a world full of atheists you
know he just
it is nobody's scared of Satan anymore
yeah
oh well
dad's a good [__] deliver man you
could say you could write too
okay back to the show okay thank you
yeah
um yeah so as I said because this kid
you know
he was kind of
you know not really that good looking
like I said he was real pimply you know
he had a speech impediment so obviously
not super popular didn't really have a
lot of friends kind of got picked on and
bullied a lot
and that kind of [__]
so he graduates high school in 1957 and
he actually went into the Army Reserves
uh so you know he did the basic training
and then you know you have to go like
one weekend a month or whatever and then
so when he wasn't doing the Army
Reserves thing he was working in his
dad's Bakery and sometimes they actually
at some point I think they moved out to
California but then they moved back to
Iowa they moved to this town called
Pocahontas
and when they lived there he actually
um was a drill instructor for like the
junior Police or whatever I think it was
like a volunteer thing
now in 1960
um you know only a few years after he
graduated high school he actually
um got married he met this girl she was
a few years younger than him I've seen a
couple different I saw one documentary
that said her name was Phoebe but then I
saw another one that said her name was
Carolyn so I'm not really sure like what
her name was they weren't married very
long spoiler alert but uh but yeah I
think she was still like 17 or 18 years
old and I was like in his early 20s I
always thought Phoebe was an incredibly
sexy name it is sexy as [__] I never
meet anybody named Phoebe though
I don't think I've ever yeah I don't
think I've ever met anybody and chances
are if other than Phoebe Cates and I've
never actually met her sorry if you did
meet a girl named Phoebe she'd be about
250 pounds that's probably what would be
would be what would happen you don't
know yeah
[Laughter]
Sarah said looking like Jenny's sister
and them glasses
who me
all right come on
yeah I can be confused for a female
that's what I'm trying to say right well
except for the mustache
but you know in that [__] face man
getting ugly why not I'm getting ugly
okay starting to look like [__] one
of them Klingons
I thought I would have thought you would
like that here there now I'm not going
to cling yeah okay
so I'm [__] I'm [__] Chronos for
Venom yeah
I kind of like that it's kind of fun
actually that's another that's another
uh Halloween costume you could do you
could do you could be a Klingon yeah
from like Star Trek [__] the motion
picture yeah that would be that'd be bad
yeah
so um all right
so the first thing that they know of
like as far as crime goes that little
Robert Hansen got up to
happen in 1960 and this is uh very
common it's I think it's one of the in
it one of the um Triad of things they
always say about serial killers like
when they're younger it's usually like
cruelty to animals bedwetting and arson
those are like usually the three things
well this is arson
what he did was he had he I believe he
was 21 or 22 years old at this point
and remember how I said this is one of
those [__] that you know um
he's gonna take revenge on the whole
world because kids were mean to him at
school and girls didn't like him and
stuff so you'd think he would have
gotten over it by the time he was in his
early 20s but no you'd be wrong about
that uh he's still mad about it and he's
gonna get revenge and the way that he
gets revenge
it's a little indirect let's put it that
way
so he had I think he had this there was
this guy that worked at the bakery that
was like a kid like a teenager that he
knew
and so he you know kind of shanghai's
this kid into helping him go in burn
down the bus garage like this where they
keep all the school buses in Pocahontas
Iowa like and he goes and burns it down
and presumably just like destroys it and
he did that to like take revenge on all
the people that were that bullied him in
school and I was like how how do you
figure that's hurting them at all I
don't really understand
how how that works but okay
so so yeah so he just burned down this
there was nobody in it or anything like
he didn't hurt anybody
but he burned it down what you're saying
it looked like Dio yeah dude I do look
more like Dio but you'd have to I have
to go down I have to get down to like
120 pounds to look like Dio though but
the hair yeah
Holy Diver
in the misty morning
I can't you know I can't stay up all
night doing this [__] I gotta get up for
work in the morning so quit farting
around I know all right so uh so yeah so
he burned the [__] down uh unfortunately
for him uh the teenager that he had
recruited to help him do this stuff uh
felt bad about it and actually went to
the cops and like reported yeah
now um at this point like I said he had
gotten married only I think it was only
like six months prior to doing this
um so his wife found out that he had
burned this [__] down and she's like
what the [__] ever and she left him you
know I mean she either had it in Alder
you know asked for a divorce or
something like that
because you know what the [__]
um
so he uh actually got uh sentenced to
three years for the arson
uh but only served 20 months
now they gave him a psychiatric
assessment before he was released on
parole uh in which they found that he
had what they called an infantile
personality and I'm like yeah I mean
obviously because he was super super
obsessed with taking revenge and like
you know everybody's out to get me and I
gotta get it back and all this other
kind of stuff and he hadn't gotten over
[__] that happened like when he was a
kid in Army how old was he again he was
in his early 20s at this point at this
point he was this was 1960. as he
graduated from high school in 1957. so I
guess he was like 21 or 22.
so he gets out and he meets another
woman
thank you Hayden oh my God so I'm gonna
make 13 o'clock browsers his brows are
still around uh yeah browsers is around
sure okay
when I put the word out that me and
Jenny were gonna do this
[__] quenched gut [__] Quinn
Studios said did Maddie got you come
come with us to to [__] exoticon in
[__] Miami [__] I guess I got a a
I got a booth and everything and you in
a hotel room and
I was like well no we're not gonna
nah but uh his uh
his wife is uh Amy Quinn you can look
her up on
Twitter that's his wife
but thank you very much Hayden yeah
thank you very much that's very very
generous yeah matter of fact I've never
I haven't I've never seen I've never
seen that color before
maybe maybe once maybe once but it was I
need to start [__] up more start
making some money
putting on wigs and [__] well yeah dude
that was a good idea though I need to
make a Klingon outfit yeah I'll use my
leather craft [__] yeah there you go to
make a [__] to Klingon armor yeah
that'd be good yeah we'll do that on a
camp show there you go we have a Star
Trek version
yeah we could do like a different we
could do different things like if we
feel like it it's like sometimes I'm not
gonna feel like yeah definitely you know
what I mean yeah
have you dressed up like a [__]
Vulcan okay yeah Vulcan Federation
officer
and Klingon from Star Trek the motion
picture we're gonna have all kinds of
fun yeah yeah I think I think it's gonna
be bad Dragon strap on and [__] you know
the Klingons are built like this
[Laughter]
is gonna be some high production values
right here yeah we can't we'll make
we'll put out a video of that yeah we
don't do that on the show we'll play it
so yeah so he gets out from the arson
and he meets a young woman uh who I
think her name was Darla now like I said
as much as he's pissing and moaning
about girls not liking him he doesn't
really seem to have too much trouble
finding women that will marry him so you
know I don't know what he's complaining
about but anyway
uh so he married her in uh Autumn of
1963 and eventually they had a couple of
kids together
now during this time too
um he was also arrested several more
times
um usually for stealing [__] uh he was a
little bit of a klepto it seems
so after that like in 1967 uh that was
when he decided you know we're going to
move out to Alaska and like start over I
guess because he I guess there were like
too many bad memories where he was and
he kept getting arrested so he's like
I'm gonna go and make a fresh start like
in Alaska or whatever
so they moved out to Anchorage now I
think his wife had uh I think she had a
master's degree in education so I think
she was like a tutor or something like
that and um he ended up opening like I
said a bakery that was um actually
really really successful so he's not one
of those serial killers that you know
what they would call like a disorganized
serial killer like he kept his [__]
together he ran a business that was very
successful yeah he had a family that
apparently didn't suspect much of
anything I have heard that he was at
least verbally abusive toward them which
would not be surprising but um I don't
know if he physically abused them yeah
um most if you guys have long if if
you're long followers of the show I've
said it many times over you know I've
read a lot of books on the profiles
profiles and so stuff that came coming
out of the FBI and um
even real high functioning serial
killers like Ted Bundy they're mostly
faking
their competency he wasn't that
competent they're been competent enough
but there never as competent as they
want you to think that they are
um they're a lot they're more
intelligent
on average
especially
especially more intelligent than the
average person all right and they're way
more intelligent than the average
Criminal
but they're not as intelligent as a
really intelligent person
if they weren't that intelligent they
get caught early they never become a
serial killer right
but if they can get past three or four
without getting caught they got enough
intelligence to be a serial killer but
the thing about them though is that
sometimes if they don't get caught and I
think this happened in Robert Hansen's
case as well because he kept getting
caught for [__] but and even like sexual
assaults and stuff like that and he kept
kind of getting away with it because
he'd only get like these little slap on
the wrist type sentence type sentences
and so I think that after a while he
started to think oh well I can't get
caught like I can just do what I want
because obviously they're not going to
do anything to me so I think he kind of
got into that which he was right about
that because they didn't he didn't get
caught for like a really long time he
did [__] from like 1971 I think was
maybe his first murder and then they
didn't catch him until 1983. so he was
pretty much operating with impunity all
that time even though he was like I said
he was caught for [__] he had a big he
had a long criminal record and not just
for stealing [__] and arson either like
later on he had
um he did [__] like in the early 1970s
he actually followed a woman home
I think what had happened was that he
was in a car and she was in a car and
like he pulled up next to her and he and
she kind of like turned and was like Hey
or whatever and he was like oh did she
digs me and so he followed her back to
her apartment and like tried to drag her
out like he grabbed her and like tried
to drag her out of her [__] apartment
weird and yeah so he tried to do like
attempt and I think he did a couple of
rapes as well and he got caught for them
but he never got like much of a sentence
and like when they start when all these
bodies started to turn up in Anchorage
like they never even thought to like
look up any of this [__] even though
he's done like the exact same things
before it's the weirdest thing Man back
in the day
rape didn't carry much of a sentence
now raid cares a lot well it should
carries a lot
and if if you grab somebody and take
them to a place where they don't want to
be that's kidnapping yeah in half the
states that's a life sentence right
there and he kidnaps people like I said
right yeah and then he'd get like you
know he'd get like [__] three months
or some [__] like that yeah
for like for literally like grabbing a
woman that was just like walking down
the street or something yeah Jesus
Christ that would be kidnapping yeah
well it is kidnapping yeah you can't
play with that [__] man yeah because
otherwise the [__] to turn out
like this most southern states that's
life or something close to life like 50.
you know and they're not playing all
right they don't play yeah and like I
said you shouldn't play because yeah
because dudes that'll do that [__]
it's this type of dude yeah it's this
type of dude yeah and they're not gonna
can you somewhere they're not gonna stop
doing it taking someone to a place
against their will that's a huge red
flag huge
it's something worse than death they're
going to take you somewhere and do
something slow to you yeah that's what I
mean yeah
so
I mean that I think that that's
something that they really should punish
yeah kidnapping should be a life
sentence not not this [__] like from
back then where it's like he literally
like you know abducts a woman and like
either rapes or attempts to rape her and
they're just like oh it's fine he can go
back on the street after three six
months he's not hurting anybody most of
the kidnappings involve like
parents fighting over children they take
the children I don't I think a lot of
times that's an exemption
second above the second behind that is
um
a dude
gets dumped by his girlfriend he grabs
his girlfriend throws her in the car he
tries to take her somewhere
you know to get back with her that's
also kidnapping all right
um but no those dudes a lot do a lot of
time for that but grabbing a stranger
and abducting them trying to take them
that's a life yeah well like I said I
ought to be because that's not good
that's not gonna lead anywhere good
people doing [__] like that
yeah that's this type of [__]
you know you're right
so uh so yeah
so he moves to Anchorage
with his family and for a while it seems
like maybe
um you know this whole starting a new
life thing is gonna work out you know he
opens the bakery
um and he starts hunting like in the
wilderness and he's actually really good
at it he's like a really good crossbow
Hunter and stuff like that
um and he like has all these records I
think that that record book with like
you know the person that shot the
biggest whatever like with the crossbar
or whatever and he had like a bunch of
Records in there
so he was kind of like known around town
as being like a really good crossbow
Hunter and [__] like that so and like I
said he had like all those trophies in
his house also
however he just couldn't
keep it together he couldn't keep it
together in 1977 he was arrested again
this time for stealing a chainsaw from a
department store
now he actually got five years for that
which is crazy because like I said some
other like rapes and [__] like that he'd
get like three months six months but
[__] you still have chainsaw from a
department store and they put in The
Slammer for five years
so they did a um I don't think he did
all five years though
but um so they do like the you know the
psychiatric evaluation on them or
whatever
and they determined that he um had
bipolar disorder
and uh actually the prison psychiatrist
said that they should make him take
lithium
um but that you know obviously they
can't really enforce that like once he
was let out so as far as I know he never
did take it
um so as I mentioned earlier uh in the
early 1980s uh Hanson did some insurance
fraud by reporting to the police that
all of this stuff had been stolen from
his house uh but really he had just
hidden it and he got uh thirteen
thousand dollars for the insurance
company and uh so that with that he
bought like I said he either like had
either bought the bakery in the plane or
he just bought the plane and had the
bakery before I'm not real clear on that
um so yeah
now
so they had uh so back to the kind of
present day where we were
so they bring Hanson back to the police
headquarters and they're asking him
about uh the murders and stuff like that
um
now because they had they did charge him
they didn't charge him with any murders
at first but they did have some other
stuff they did because he you know the
guns they found his house it was like
weapons violations they had him on the
insurance fraud uh and theft and things
like that so it's like well we have
things to hold him on until we can get
enough evidence like for the murder ship
so
um in late 1983 uh they actually had
four indictments against him uh some
first degree assault and kidnapping that
was for the Cindy Paulson case
um five counts of misconduct possession
of a handgun theft in second degree
theft by deception in insurance fraud so
they were still waiting for the
ballistics test to come back from that
rifle that they found to tie him in with
the murders that was like some of the
physical evidence position of a handgun
well it was a handgun that he wasn't
supposed to have like there was a the
one that they found like up in the thing
why wasn't he supposed to have that I
don't know this is this is Alaska I know
but I just well I don't know I don't
know I'm just telling you what it says
in Alaska
it's not it's not Canada and and at this
time
that's that's odd well misconduct and
possession of a handgun so that might
have had to do with the fact that he was
like doing something wrong and had a gun
on him right that's what I mean to
because he had the handgun while he was
abducting right that's what Cindy
Paulson is what it was not so much The
Possession right right right right not
so much
firearm in other words
he was in the commission of a violent
crime with a firearm which is what the
so it's an enhancement is what they're
talking about right okay like I said
they were just trying to like
they were just trying to like get some
major indictments against him until like
more evidence came in for the murder
charges because they really wanted to
charge him with that right but they had
all this other stuff to like hold him on
so finally they get the ballistics tests
back oh no drink and yeah and uh we'll
surprise no one to know that the rifle
that they found under his insulation in
the Attic was indeed the same rifle that
had killed uh you know the women that
they found you know the shell casings
and everything like that
so at this point
um basically they were like
they wanted him to confess is what they
wanted what they ended up doing was that
because he wouldn't confess at first
like he basically just was like he
wouldn't really tell them much of
anything that they didn't already know
so they actually went back to another
woman
um that he had raped back in the early
70s
and asked her if she would like come
testify
and they wanted to get Cindy Paulson to
testify as well
um you know against him so he did have
like I said because he had had some
sexual assaults on his record prior to
all of this happening like from the 70s
like but he hadn't killed anybody they
think that his first murder was in 71
but they're not entirely sure like I
said they're not entirely sure how many
people he's killed but it's at least 17
and probably more
so basically what they did was they
offered him they said look we'll tell
you what
if you
give us a full confession tell us
everything that happened
um we'll only charge you with the four
murders that we know about they're like
because look we know that we've killed
that you've killed like a lot more
people than just those four but those
are the ones that they add evidence in
like the ones that they had found the
bodies and
um you know they said so if you confess
to that then uh you know you'll be able
to they actually offered him they said
you'd be able to serve time at a federal
prison
um instead of uh you know like a super
max or maximum security or whatever
so
um he said okay
after that they got the full confession
out of Robert Hansen I don't know if his
entire confession is because I know it
was recorded I've heard
um significant clips of it but I don't
know if the whole thing is somewhere
like you know and I've read like bits of
the transcript or whatever
but basically what he said he would do
was he would
just kind of like drive up and down
because you know he worked at a bakery
so that's kind of like weird hours you
know because they have to be there in
the middle of the night to kind of get
all the stuff ready for the morning and
everything
so when he got off work he would drive
um you know up and down like the red
light district and just see you know
women walking around prostitute sex
workers whatever
and then he would
um say something like and this is
actually like a quote from his
confession
he says uh I pull out the gun and he
says to them look you're a professional
you don't get excited you know there's
some risk to what you've been doing if
you do exactly what I tell you you're
not going to get hurt you're just gonna
count this off as a bad experience and
be a little more careful next time who
you're going to proposition or go out
with
and then he said that he tried to act as
tough as he could to get them as scared
as possible
um he said he would hold their head back
put a gun in their face get them to feel
helpless scared
and um yeah so he said he was just
trying to get control of the situation
just like a cop would that's basically
what he was saying
so he said so after that what he would
do
um you know he would handcuff them
and then he would
he said well for a while he what he
couldn't take them to the house because
obviously his wife and kids were there
but when um he actually sent his wife
and kids away to Europe that summer
specifically so he could bring victims
back there because he wanted to do that
he called it his summer project
these [__] [__] I swear to
God so yeah
but what he would do um you know he
would take them uh you know you put them
in the plane and then fly them out to
his cabin he'd have like this kind of
Shack out there
and so he was doing it out of the cabin
at first and he would take them out
there he would tie them up he would like
rape and torture them and then he would
take all their clothes off blindfold
them and set them free out in the woods
give them a little bit of a head start
and then hunt them down like an animal
is what he would do
uh sometimes he would like toy with them
for a really long time
um I've heard that he would even
sometimes like kind of sneak around
behind him like with a hunting knife and
like kind of cut at their legs and [__]
like that so he would wound them and
then like follow the blood trail and
crap like that or like sometimes
um I just like on one other documentary
that I was
watching because I watched like a whole
bunch of different documentaries this is
his story or the survival or a story
from a survivor no as far as I know I
don't think anybody survived that he
took out in the woods and actually and
actually one of the women
um I think like did get it but then she
died of exposure later on but most of
them they I mean they found them later
that were like so she got away from him
and then she died from the cold right
well yeah because she didn't have any
clothes her shoes on yeah because he was
yeah so he was out there like I said he
was out there doing some most dangerous
game [__] yeah see because the reason
why I'm calling [__] on this because
it's hard to sneak up on somebody really
well yeah I know that but like I said
they you know they're out there naked
and terrified with the blindfold on
oh the blindfolds on him when they're
running yeah yeah he put like an Ace
bandage over there eyes no damn so he
where's the sporting at
and uh and they're handcuffed
yeah I'm not sure if he handcuffed all
of them they didn't take the blindfold
off they didn't say anything about
finding handcuffs on some of the bodies
they did find the Ace bandages though
like on some of the like the around the
eyes well they must have been there
maybe they could there hadn't been a way
they must have been handcuffed behind
the back that way they couldn't take the
blindfold off yeah
Ben said sometimes he would fly his
plane and shoot them from the air I
don't know if he did that though like I
never I didn't read that anywhere but
maybe he did that'd be hard to do yeah
he took a shot from uh from there I
think he would normally just like take
them to the cabin and then like let them
free and like run around
and he kind of he got his jollies like
that
like letting him run around and he would
shoot him and a lot of them like the
ones they found the bodies they found
like they were shot in the back so like
I said how [__] sporting is that not
very
so yeah
um as you might note this is very much
like the story The Most Dangerous Game
which came out that it's a story came
out in the 1920s and they've made it
into a movie like 40 bajillion times if
you've ever seen like a I I read it in
school did you read in school yeah I was
watching um
because Simon Whistler wouldn't it yeah
yeah yeah because Simon Whistler um you
know the Casual criminalist show that he
does he did a show about uh Robert
Hansen and he he had never read the most
dangerous game and I said well I thought
everybody read it in school
maybe they don't read it in school
anymore no they changed education man
they don't educate people anymore
they used to [__] give you all
there's all kinds of classic literature
you had to read
you had to read Charles Dickens well I
think they still do that I'm just saying
that you that sometimes the you know
what they read like changes and maybe
that just fell off the curriculum I
don't know but I just I remember reading
it in school
okay Beowulf yeah it's [__] um
[__] uh because it was part of
English Lit very wolf
um most dangerous game I mean that's a
short story great Temptations what's a
great it was no Great Expectations great
expectation yeah we read that too
um there's a bunch of them I had to read
mayor of casterbridge yeah I don't think
I read that one
I remember reading that one in 10th
Grade and there's a bunch of poetry you
had to read he had to read a bunch of
Emily Dickinson and [__] yeah yeah
Robert Herrick yeah read about
Jabberwockies and [__]
that's Lewis Carroll yeah I like that
poem though yeah
I like that I liked English Lit yeah
Scarlet Letter we read The Scarlet
Letter yeah I remember that one I was I
actually really liked that book I don't
know
um what was the other one Crucible no
yeah we were well that's yeah that's
Arthur Miller That's the play about that
yeah yeah we read that and I read that
in 10th or 11th grade
our town I remember yeah Thornton Wilder
and I'm trying to remember all the [__]
we had to read did a lot of Shakespeare
Romeo and Juliet Midsummer I stream yeah
Midsummer's Night Dream remember though
yeah
[Music]
A Tale of Two Cities
I read that one on my own
we read that in school that was uh
Alexander Dumas wouldn't it no no that's
Charles Dickens yeah that's right
Charles he wrote uh [__] uh Count of
Monte Cristo yeah yeah it was that
[__] Original Gangster story about
getting out of prison and [__]
becoming a player and getting revenge on
the people that locked you up
who stole your wife from you that was a
good one
Ben said um they made you read that at
school what
they made us read what at school or uh
mayor casterbridge is my favorite
classic novel I didn't really you know
what it's Thomas Hardy right and it's
like I didn't really like the mayor of
Castro bridge I should probably like
reread it however
um Thomas Hardy's one of Thomas Hardy's
other books Jude the Obscure is probably
one of my favorite uh it's probably one
of my favorite classic novels even
though it's the most depressing [__]
ever but that's probably why I like it
um yeah Jane Eyre yeah I think we read
that too
do we read Jenner yeah I'm pretty sure
Frankenstein we read Frankenstein
I'm trying to remember we read a bunch
of stuff
um okay
so yeah we got distracted because the
most dangerous game I'm just saying I
remember reading that short story it was
in like a compilation of short stories
that we read in school because it was
that one and The Lottery by Shirley
Jackson and uh Rose for Emily that was
another one we read so yeah it was just
like you know short stories
so um basically so Robert Hansen
confesses to all this [__]
and then they give him a big map uh you
know because they're like look we know
that you killed a lot of people and you
buried them out here
so he pointed out
15 uh sites that he remembered burying
bodies
12 of these uh were previously unknown
to investigators
now
um they decided they were going to like
put him in a plane and fly him out to
each thing so he could point the bodies
out to them the [__] up thing about
this is that when they took him out
there you know it's Alaska it's like all
covered with snow and it's like out in
the wilderness and stuff and they said
the [__] up thing was that they would
take him to some of the sites and they
were like he got like visibly like
really jazzed and like really excited
like oh well like and he's like digging
in the snow like she's around here
somewhere you know what I mean like he
was like super happy about it and it's
like that is
that's [__] up but he was very very
excited to like show them where the
[__] bodies were or to like revisit
the [__] I don't really know like I
don't know
so yeah so they flam out to each
location and uh they you know found a
bunch more bodies uh you know so they
ended up I believe that they found even
though
um he actually confessed as far as I
know to killing 17. I think
um they found
okay they found the um the bodies they
found at the beginning but then they
found 12 more bodies okay but some of
the other ones that he confessed to
killing they have not found their bodies
and like I said the first one they found
which was um the unidentified woman that
she's still not identified
you know what was it
yeah Annie or whatever he probably
didn't know who she was either did he
well I yeah like nobody knew nobody knew
so um so yeah
basically what they did so even though
he showed them where all these other
bodies were
and he confessed to 17 murders
um and 30 rapes on top of that like you
know the women that lived uh they you
know because of the deal they were only
going to charge him with the four
murders you know that they knew about
um which were Sherry Morrow uh Joanna
Messina Paula Golding and uh aklutna
Annie so those were the ones they had
the most evidence for so they just
charged him with four
but uh the judge was like well if even
it's just four murders we're not letting
this [__] back out of the street
so they basically sentenced him to
461 years plus life on top of that uh it
was like this [__] is never
getting out uh you know which finally I
mean it took him long enough
um to do that but yeah so um they did
end up finding uh seven bodies where uh
he pointed out the grave sites but they
haven't recovered any other uh bodies
some of them it was just too you know it
was just too far out in the wilderness
or you know there's animals and stuff
like that so some of the bodies were
perhaps eaten or did he give many
details about what happened during these
hunts
not so I don't think so not so much like
he just kind of got off on
watching the naked girls just like
running around and just shooting at them
yeah all right like you know what I mean
he's
he said he would sometimes like wait
like I said he'd give him a head start
and
nothing about what they said or anything
maybe they didn't I don't think so I
mean what could you possibly say I'm
sure someone might try to talk the way
out of it well I'm sure most of them did
right
I was kind of thinking well I was just
like I said I was just watching um The
Frozen Ground which is the 2013 movie
that they made about this guy
and they kind of showed one situation
where you know the girl was out there
and uh you know he was chasing her and
she was doing that she was just
basically like you know why don't you
just let me go and also I'm like I'm
sure they probably all said that yeah
but then I was thinking to myself it's
like I don't even know if I was in that
situation I don't you know I'm
thankfully I've never been in that
situation but
um you know would I even bother no that
dude's [__] he's he's too far to be
too far gone to be reasoned with just
run but I mean that's really like the
only thing you can think to do I guess
but it's like I don't really shame is
that one of them got away and then she
froze to death
as far as I remember yeah I think one of
them did get away and um and then she
died of exposure because you know it's
the Wilderness she probably got lost and
she didn't have any clothes or shoes or
she may have been handcuffed too yeah
maybe
well you said they're wearing a
blindfold so yeah there's got to be a
reason why they can't take the blind I
mean I don't know if they all were but
that was one thing that they did fine he
pulls a gun on him tells him to freeze
and goes up and blindfolds him and
shoots him yeah like an execution yeah
he would like shoot him in the back but
he let him like run away though and like
let him run around for a little while
because I guess he liked them to be
scared
yeah but so the other bodies you
probably weren't scared they're probably
pissed off huh they probably weren't
even scared they're probably just pissed
off
think about it
because they're not in captivity they're
just running they're probably this
[__] you know what I mean yeah
they're just running probably how much I
bet
it never goes down the way they imagine
it
they're probably calling him all kinds
of [__] I'd be cussing at him
well yeah I probably would too yeah so
I'm thinking those girls were probably
like that too
probably calling him a [__] ass coward
and everything
uh Ben said oh the most dangerous game
seems odd for required reading in the
80s yeah I mean I guess so but like I
said it wasn't so much it was just kind
of like like I said we had like this big
huge like English book that had like a
bunch of short stories in it and that
was just like one of the short stories
yeah in the textbook yeah and like I
said it's now that I think about it
maybe it's just the ones that I
remembered were the gruesome ones yeah
but most dangerous game yeah Telltale
Heart yeah in the head hitting a
pendulum in there too yeah that's right
yeah a lot of Edgar on power yeah and um
yeah so but like I said I remember all
the gruesome ones like Like A Rose for
Emily that's a pretty gruesome story and
the lottery which is a really [__] up
story
um you know what I mean we read a lot of
[__] up stuff in the 80s oh Cask of
montiago was in there yeah
yeah there was a lot of Poe in there I
don't know now that I'm thinking about
it mask of the Red Death yeah that was
in there too yeah yeah I mean I don't
know if that was one book I think there
might have been two books I think we're
thinking I think we're combining two
years together
well I'm just saying you're in senior
year I'm just talking about everything
that I can remember from Junior High in
high school that we had to read I don't
remember that much from junior high but
I remember High School
most of the stuff that we had to read
for high school that was one of my
favorite classes
yeah yeah that was one of my favorite
classes too not so much in 10th Grade
because I didn't like the teacher but
11th grade the T our teacher was awesome
I liked I liked all my classes except
anything mathematics and algebra [__]
that [__] was hard I hated it hated it
and [__]
this is like known science but they
don't give a [__]
the frontal lobes of [__] men
really don't develop until early 20s
you're really not intelligent enough to
[__] absorb a lot of the mathematics
a lot of [__] that they're teaching you
and if you can absorb it then there's
something wrong with you if you're a man
if you're a guy they've looked at it and
they've said they forget that I saw a
[__] program on it this is the lower
the lower the testosterone levels in
those boys the better they do
the higher the testosterone the worse
that they do
and that's because it's and that's
beyond that's across all males of all
different ethnic groups
boys should be go to middle school and
then they should be out of school at
Middle School
they should go back to high school
around 20. that's when you can educate
them
and that and that's how you finish them
up during
those teenage years those that they need
to be in some kind of a [__] activity
you know something kind of like the
military is where they need to be
doing construction
playing sports [__] like that
having sex that's what they should be
doing
so um okay so I was trying to
um say who the other victims were
the other seven bodies that they found
so these were the other seven bodies
that they found that they have
identified uh their names were Sue Luna
uh Malai Larson Dylan Frye Teresa Watson
Angela federn Tamara Peterson and Lisa
Futrell those were the other ones that
they found all women that were around
the same age that had been uh Missing
for some time
so uh so yeah
uh as I said they have not identified or
they haven't found like the other ones
that he confessed to killing and they
still have not identified
um
Annie like you know the the first one
that they found they said that when they
found her
um you know the only description they
have she was a white woman uh brunette
in her 20s wearing knee-high reddish
brown high-heeled boots jeans a
sleeveless knit top and a brown leather
jacket she also had a silver cuff
bracelet with polished stones in it that
was possibly handmade so they're hoping
still that someone will be able to
identify her but so Hansen like I said
461 years he got plus life
and uh so he actually got they actually
put him in prison in Pennsylvania for a
little while because I guess he didn't
want to be in prison in Alaska but then
they moved him back to Alaska afterward
and Seward and then he was there until
his death in 2014. he died of some
unspecified natural causes uh at the age
of 75.
um remember how I said earlier that he'd
kind of been known as like a big game
hunter and he had like a bunch of
Records in
um that Pope and Youngs is what they
call it which is like the kind of like I
guess it's like the Guinness Book of
World Records for hunters or whatever
and um they actually uh scrubbed his
name out after all of this [__] came out
which you know he can't really [__]
blame him can you you didn't drink any
of this well yeah well I'm trying to
talk I'm trying to finish the show so
it's kind of hard to drink it a long
time ago I know but it's hard to drink
and talk at the same time you want me to
drink some of it for you no I'm just
saying that
it's kind of hard to like do two things
at once you know what I mean I can't
you know what I mean I can't do like 40
things at once okay you know what I'm
saying
and then I drink and you don't talk I'm
gonna drink some and then you just kind
of sit there
Ben said he lost his records for hunting
because his witness to the kills was the
same guy who gave him a false Alibi for
his crime oh I didn't know that I never
heard that anywhere
who what was that guy's name Henning
can you I mean
that guy didn't know what he was up to
right did he because
I kind of feel like he felt really bad
because he went to the cops later
because I think it was his wife that
came out like when the cops are
searching the house and said
um hey what's going on and like the cop
said oh we think that
I don't think they said hey we think
he's a serial killer because they
wouldn't say that but to your neighbor
but they might have said oh you know we
want him like with this murder
investigation and she's like oh my
husband said that he was uh with him on
that particular day and that was
[__] he wasn't and then I think the
husband actually did go to the cops
later and retracted his confession so I
think that or you know his Alibi so I
think that he did feel bad about it but
I don't know
it seemed like he was one of those
[__] like BTK that like was
just everyone just thought oh he's the
guy that owns the bakeries Baker Bob
yeah you know what I mean and like
nobody and he made like really good
cookies and [__] like that apparently
apparently and like all the cops went
there and had donuts and whatnot and so
I don't think anybody suspected him
really even though he had like a really
long criminal record and and even he had
a criminal record of like doing similar
[__] like I said like abducting and
raping women it's just that he kind of
like got away with it and it seemed like
no one really checked
which like I said I kind of feel like
nowadays they would do that but I know
it was harder back then because
either they didn't have a National
Database and all that but still I mean
you'd think I don't know how accurate
that National Database actually is even
today
well I'm sure it was better than back
then though it's like back then they
didn't like [__] know [__] why do you
think it took so long to catch
[__] back then you moved to
another state and like they most of the
time unless you did something really
egregious I don't think they would even
like think to check like other states
records like where you came from or
nothing yeah you had to hit the news
right for something bad and then like
somebody in the other like the national
news that guy oh [__] like I'm gonna
call the cops in that state it's like
that's like so yeah that's what I mean
you had to do something really really
bad that like it got on the national
news so somebody else would hear about
it and like yeah look into it yeah right
so you know up until fairly recently I
think that was the case and honestly we
I don't think we've brought this up
before but maybe that was another reason
why
serial killers seem to get away with
like they had like much longer careers
if you want to call it that
um you know back in the 60s and 70s
maybe for that reason too because you
could just kind of go to another state
and yeah no computers yeah no computer
so it's like unless somebody you know
yeah if somebody had the wherewithal to
like check you know they'd find out your
[__] but you know a lot of times they
wouldn't have a reason to you know if
nobody suspected you of anything like
why would you oh where is this
[__] from oh Iowa let's go check
the records in Iowa and see if he did
some [__] there you know what I mean you
wouldn't check you wouldn't have a
reason
even today it it'd be hard to catch the
serial killer that is moving a lot and a
lot of them are constantly moving
they're on the road they're truckers and
[__] like that
that's the most common one
because you're killing people in one
[__] jurisdiction and dropping them
off the body off in another
those are the ones that get away with it
the longest
um Ben said wasn't he on parole for
raping a boy when he started the bakery
I'm not really sure about that I hadn't
like um seen that on anything but it's
possible he was um he had done some
rapes before but as far as as I know
they were women like he um
he either raped or attempted to rape
like a housewife like that was one case
and she I don't think she's ever been
named and he um there was like an
attempted rape kidnapping like on a girl
like I said that he had followed home
because he just saw her in a car or
something and followed her to her
apartment and tried to abduct her so I
know there was that and they're like I
said that kind of thing is never like an
isolated incident dudes that do that
they probably do that kind of [__] all
the time so I would imagine
that he is probably raped and killed
substantially more people than they
think
like I said they're pretty sure
they know he killed 17 people
um but they said that they're on the map
you know the map that they found in his
house I think there were 21 X's which
would denote grave sites because almost
all of the exes were gravesites I think
they checked some of them and there was
nothing there but like I said it was
maybe because you know animals had
gotten to them
um but he didn't confess
well he confessed to 17. all right but
um
then they pointed out too that that map
might only be part of like another maybe
you know he has a map of another area
where he's you know hiding but he
particularly liked that area around the
Knick River I guess because he was
familiar with it you'd think that he
would want credit for all of them yeah
you'd think that too but like I said I'm
I'm not really sure there were 21 x's on
the map as far as I'm aware
um and he's 17 21 that's not a big leap
so right he must be 21 right
but then like I saw another thing that
said maybe as many as 37 and I'm not
really sure where they're getting that
total from but I mean there must be some
reason why they came up with that
so you know what I mean yeah
uh Ben said his first crime that got him
locked up was burning down a school bus
shed yeah that was um and like I said
that's pretty common with some serial
killers like doing it's like I said it's
usually cruelty to animals or arson or
something like that and it was done as
revenge against like bullies at school
for some reason I don't know why the
bullies at school would care that he
burned down the school bus thing but
symbolic I suppose Ben also said Alaska
was a bit of a wild west state where
people hiding out tended to move to
apparently yeah I think there was uh and
Mr 88 said that's still the case yeah I
kind of feel like it still is I mean
it's like the population is probably
much higher now than it was back then
but
um it did have a reputation back then
for being very wild west that's kind of
where you went if you wanted to
kind of Lose Yourself or start over Anew
like if you were in trouble someplace
else or something like that so there was
like a lot of transient elements a lot
of criminal elements a lot of that kind
of stuff you know what I mean so you
know
Camp guy said uh David Berkowitz started
over a thousand fires he wrote them down
in a journal Berkowitz did a thousand
fires I didn't know about that I didn't
either
right it's like yeah you've got to be
some kind of like weirdo obsessive
too I mean I enjoy writing things down
too like so I can remember it later but
I I can't imagine why well I mean why
would you write down what what's
exciting about that like one fire is
pretty much like another fire right no
they've sexualized that [__] I've seen
[__] programs on master arsonists
that are just
can do amazing things just with a
cigarette lighter
I mean
me and you walk around don't see
anything but he sees it and goes man if
I put a cigarette lighter right there
that whole [__] fencil burn that Trio
get caught and then it will go and it'll
climb and it'll get into that apartment
complex and once that goes up it I mean
they could and then they'll do it
yeah
and if I can just with it but only a
pyro thinks like that isn't it sad that
like people have
quote unquote talents like that and it's
like you know if they use that for
something productive like they could
probably like do some really cool [__]
but no
it's well for them it's sexual yeah and
um when the firemen show up they're
if they think they have a suspected
arson arsonist in the area
they'll have guys looking to look in the
looking at the witnesses
and they're like surreptitiously taking
pictures of the witnesses to see if
Witnesses repeat
and uh they'll grab a guy
if he's the suspect and reach into his
pockets and see if his pants got pockets
in them or if there's a hole in the
pocket yeah because they're reaching
through their [__] pocket and jerking
it yeah while the fire is happening yeah
so they know what to look for they got
invest arson investigators that know all
about that kind of [__]
you really need to [__] get a [__]
ton of training and figure out how to
get into the mindset of a dude that's
like jerks off to fire
I mean that's an alien concept to me
like like intellectually I understand it
but like I don't
you know like I can see how you get from
one thing to the other but it's just
like I don't I can't relate to it though
no
that's some weird [__] it is pretty
weird I get it because and evidently
they start jerking off to things that
will burn
yeah it's not even fun it's not even on
fire but they just go oh there it is
it flash paper
there it is if I put that on fire it'll
spread and it'll go up here and it'll go
it'll be the biggest thing ever and
evidently they just can't take it
it's some weird [__] man it is weird
people people have uh it'd be like
seeing a pile of [__] nude bodies and
going oh you know what I mean like oh I
gotta get that you know
they all look so good
I don't know man
I'm gonna touch fire to it I'm gonna
touch fire to it yeah and then they
can't control it I don't know you look
like you're doing a pretty good job like
faking it right there yeah yeah
I could [__] star in a movie of Pyro
with that wig on this wig and everything
man are you gonna set that wig on fire
no that'll be the end beautiful hair has
the beautiful hair has to be part of the
Pyro image
oh my God all right so uh it's getting
kind of late maybe we should like wrap
it up it's uh quarter to ten okay oh
[__] yeah yeah I gotta I gotta go to bed
soon because I gotta get up really early
yeah but uh turn it down and thank you
we had a big spender today uh we did
yeah Hayden Santos yep thank you very
much actually thank you very much
everybody everybody who [__] gave us
who contributed this evening uh yeah
this was actually like I said this is a
[__] up topic but you guys know I I
like the True Crime ones
because I don't know I just find them a
lot
it's really compelling so even though
they're [__] up they're good yeah and
they're popular with the audience
audience yeah I mean who doesn't like
your crime it's like you know what I
mean I know it's I know we're like sick
and twisted but you know
it is like really interesting and this
guy I feel like
I've been wanting to do a show about him
for a while because he's such a [__]
monster but you know what I mean all
right so uh I guess that will do it for
the show this evening uh we'll be back
on Friday night for the side track show
might get a little bit more into
it's our upcoming project because I
don't really want to talk about it on
this show because you know what I mean
so I wanted to like keep [__] like kind
of serious because we're talking about
like serious topics you know what I mean
but Friday we can
we can just drink and [__] around yeah
like we usually do I get paid Friday I
don't know let's see oh yeah that's
right it might be might be payday well I
get paid Friday okay so that'll be
something we might go out we'll see I
mean yeah we'll we'll see what's going
on I'm not really sure but uh but yeah
we didn't go out this past weekend it
was nice to kind of save some money
but uh all right so we will see you guys
again on Friday night thank you very
much for dropping by hopefully you
enjoyed the show and we will see you
guys again on Friday bye